check it clouds and dirt I'm actually
opening with that now you got your
prospective go to Chiba and you'll want
to go to Chiba
[Music]
say my name louder now keep that energy
we're not gonna tell
don't waste my sorry I don't know where
you I used to help look all your stuff
and I was a CA no [ __ ]
yeah well that's amazing with Peter and
Nadler no that's awesome man thought you
had neither yes awesome
it's great to see man mozz what up my
man what up what up what up
see how are you thank you so much and
sir I'm about to go on Network and sell
for the first time ever your black
clouds and dirt download the app
somebody once you going through the chat
and help help people understand the [ __ ]
we're doing so what they can just
download the app it's it's only it's
only iPhone that's good cuz [ __ ]
Android sucks
[Applause]
I'm just kidding I'm kidding I'm just
what I'm trying to call the cops I hate
it by the way there's only one reason on
earth why I hate Andrew Andy tell
everybody this story about when you
decided to go rogue and get Android how
long's you own an Android phone what
what happened so I said I sent a text
message I was like oh [ __ ] green
why's your [ __ ] green and greens my
favorite color so imagine how much I
hate that it's you know why it is though
you'll love this the only reason nobody
on my team has Android is because I have
to be able to text while I'm on Wi-Fi on
planes cuz that's where I do all my work
and if I can't text you Oh Caleb you or
Android [ __ ] crime like I'm Gary I
love it man Congrats Congrats you when I
was like
I've been watching you stuff that makes
me so happy you're doing it wrong
thank you hey does Emily she's also the
show thanks for having me no solution
yeah I'm super excited about it yeah
it's gonna be awesome it's gonna be cool
looking forward to it you know what up
everybody going on Network live2sell the
new clouds and earth dark sky are clouds
right dark clouds
she's the name so many times only way to
get it internationally twenty minutes be
ready everybody it's gary b we're going
live 6 p.m. PST 9 p.m. EST check it
clouds and dirt I'm doing it ever I'm
actually opening with that now I'm gonna
open with that being sure to be working
we've been working so the O 3 the first
version was the white colourway
clouds and dirt kind of my my thesis on
life right have a macro vision all the
big stuff but then you gotta get your
hands dirty and put in the work be in
the studio be the entrepreneur put in
the actual work so many people talking
about clouds but not willing to do the
dirt these days on fake entrepreneurs on
Instagram so I wanted to put this out
and then Barney the team Tyler might
rest of my crew they're like hey let's
do a secret kind of color way and let's
do a black on the reverse and then I was
thinking about it I wanted to do it but
then I was like what are we gonna call
it and then calling it dark clouds got
me excited because I think the biggest
thing that people don't talk about with
entrepreneurship is that 99% of it is
[ __ ] and lonely and tough and bad and
dark and so I'm in a weird way I
associate even more with that part of
the journey that nobody wants to talk
about on social right let's talk about
your very positive so I want to talk
about both of you I'm sure you get
there's a lot of hate there's a lot of
negative emotions lying I'm learning how
do you deal with it because does it ever
get to your head
you know for me it's like look I think
when somebody leaves negativity on a
post on social media that's an indicator
about them not me like I've never nor I
will I ever take time to consume
somebody's content and then leave some
hey that's just a complete waste of time
so honestly I look at it with compassion
and empathy when I see that stuff I just
feel bad that somebody's in a place
where they need to drag somebody down
and so for me negativity and fear they
can have a little love in the short term
you can win a little with that game but
long-term positivity and love always
wins the game what I want to say real
quick is if you're not buying this shoe
right now and swiping whatever
functionality this app does you've got
that down shopping cart below if you're
not buying this you're breaking my heart
and for all the people flipping by like
10 and flip them and I'll give you
exposure really fun of course I'm for
reselling that's how I grew up I hate
when people become hypocrites when they
free sold and when they were coming up
stood in line and flipped but when they
got their own [ __ ] like I only want
people to buy honestly this is like one
of this one we both I think I only made
5,000 like I want everybody who's
watching now buy it relist it on eBay
for 200 and I'll give you exposure make
your money that blows my [ __ ] mind
people that are anti reselling are
literally just hating on people that are
like I don't understand that logic like
like look by the way if people want to
wear them great but like if somebody
else wants some more and you can't get
them the best the reason I wanted to do
this with network is this is now
available internationally otherwise
we're not right so like somebody
watching right now in Australia or UK or
things of that nature this is the only
way and so as you could imagine and it's
a $50 shipping point so they're in for a
buck 50 right but I know they can get
330 and I want I want them to I want
them to make that 180 bucks because if
that matters more to them than rocking
it that's them everyone's selfish look
you hurt my feelings it's [ __ ]
ridiculous
for real the younger generation is so
like into being negative like they think
it's cool to be sad yeah I mean look
emo and like that there's always that I
I think a hundred percent every 13 16 19
years got always have angst the problem
is is that people just don't have
perspective right they don't understand
that it's impossible to be a human being
like it's impossible like that's the
rarest [ __ ] in the world and so they
just people taking for granted taking
for granted
take it for granted yeah respect flips
gangsters out there Andy
sighs got it up for 600 575 in pairs
people trying to make that money
business since you've into it look I
mean you know first of all being the
sneaker business is the best I'll tell
you why it's it's so established as I
anchor in our lives
I think sneakers are no different than
meaning the jeans business for last
night you know 70 years like it's not
going anywhere the vulnerabilities are
too much fragmentation too much you know
non actual brand building I think one of
things that I've been very cautious of
that I've been trying to be a great
partner of is how much love I give
k-swiss you know like of course them to
Gary but like you know tagging always
and like always bringing you guys up and
like like it's important to me to be
that good of a partner so I think
finding the right balance for the brand
is important but what do I see look I
think that there's an amazing
opportunity for a lot of people to carve
out the long tail and that's what's
happening in every business I think
there's an incredible opportunity to
lean in heavier to some of these
boutiques and micro franchises so to me
the guys and gals opening up six or
seven store
timer interesting while supporting the
big players that we all work with on the
sales side I think there's an
opportunity to tap in even heavier to
long tail influencers and I think
there's a there's opportunities to be
ultra creative like I've been thinking
about a lot of stuff of like what if I
made a sneaker that was biodegradable
where like my whole pitch was wearing
for a week and then bury him in the
ground like what if my sneaker became a
tree okay listen listen innovation is
wild and you just never know and like as
people become more thoughtful about the
environment and things that nature like
trends trends eSports you know we've
talked a lot about that thank you for
having me guys take care thank you yeah
no you're right
I'm like why are we gonna thirteen I
would walk the thirteen but I think
we're a or no wife for pleasure man
a pleasure what up I know a lot of you
that I [ __ ] with are gonna be a complex
con Tyler and I are plotting right now
hit up Tyler I'm tagging them right now
I want to see you come by the booth or
I'll come to you there's a bunch of you
that I know want to take that photo or
give that love to
I want to live in LA sometimes right
whether it's legit I'm clearly I'm
clearly buying a place when the economy
collapses in LA 100 thousand percent
yeah hundred thousand percent for me I'm
just like I'm in constant mode you know
generating about hours I don't think
about anything I'm just like don't
[ __ ] think I'm not trying to come
over for the night yeah I think one of
them's a most fascinated by right now is
there's so much money in this system and
if you follow where the money comes from
that's an interesting thing to debate in
the first place but let's leave that for
another day I I am fascinated by people
thinking that not making more profit
than expenses is not something you need
to think about a lot more like I'm just
watching people spend all their time on
like you know influencer marketing and
kack and M&A and like all this like when
the money dries out like there there's a
lot of young people in the system you
didn't live through 2007 as an operator
you were in college having fun you
didn't live through 2001 we have never
been this over-leveraged we have never
been this over-leveraged and when the
dominoes fall and there's no next
fundraising round or when you're an
influencer and nobody's got $8,000 for
you to take a picture with a [ __ ]
toothpaste in your hand
it's not gonna be fun to go from
traveling the world as an influencer to
no money in the system and you have to
go get a job like I want people to be
prepared and everyone's living in
[ __ ] la la land and we've been living
in la-la land for a decade which makes
me nervous as [ __ ] by the jets for
knowledge years you got four bucks I
love it it's nothing Jeremy thank you so
much man but to help people see the
experience that's a good-looking body
but your brother you've got 22 year olds
who'd rather have the coolest sneakers
and so they have to do things for
economics they don't understand that
that's burning the bridges for what they
actually want right it's it's it's oh
look I'm an entrepreneur I want to I
want to build businesses that make money
but there's such a way to do it in the
right way it's just lacking patience
people lack [ __ ] patience right it's
just it's short and it and then if you
take it a seed lower people care about
other people's opinions that arise and
so they do behaviors to look good to
other people it's super interesting to
me as I've you know I'm not a kid that
learns through education I have to live
in and I'm like oh oh you're doing you
oh you're doing that because you need
money you want a million dollars today
and I want 300,000 over 20 years okay I
understand oh you want a million today
cuz you want to [ __ ] take a private
jet to get the girl oh okay like you
know you suck oh [ __ ] your parents made
you insecure you know like it's some
deep [ __ ] for me it's my favorite number
literally you know it's like inner
circle homies like these characters who
like are disproportionally I peed out on
my way who worked like it's just cliche
right like they didn't look the part but
then they run the whole [ __ ] like it's
happening a beta right now Lots indie
rock evolved I love it the [ __ ] verb
it's the best and it fight but I guess I
guess that's that's the beauty and by
the way look back to kindness people
were saying kindness is the stickiest
part of keeping talent yeah I just want
to go to Chiba
[Music]
[Music]